pyon biotech is launching the tea byron
for platform for education traditional
bio informatics curriculum is too
focused on teaching how to set up by
informatics tools and then learn how to
code which is just my practical for the
majority of the students but what if
instead of teaching tools we could teach
by informatics logic using exciting
projects with public domain data from
high-impact journals and leading experts
while now you can t bio info is an
intuitive easy to use visual interface
for all types of omics data analysis the
platform covers a wide variety of data
types with a consistent user interface
and intuitive machine learning tools the
point-and-click pipeline builder hides
the complexity and makes assist them
accessible for anyone teaching the
analysis logic each button represents an
algorithm that is explained in pop-ups
with references to publications about
the methods these tools are incorporated
into our educational curriculum of
courses and tutorials covering major
topics with short lessons and quizzes
the courses utilized to lead projects
that show the power of bioinformatics
analysis in real biological experiments
that introduce the students to important
challenges in biomedicine pharma
research and agriculture at the end a
successful project that a student
completes provides a certificate that
will be supported by our academic
partners because at the end of the day
students want to use their skills to
work in a rewarding position at a
top-rated company we already launched
our beta version of the platform this
fall and have received great feedback
from our first users the courses are
being developed by experts in
bioinformatics and in collaboration with
leading academic institutions we are
excited to welcome you to join by
becoming a student teacher or partner in
this project and help us train the next
generation of politicians